Three hundred pounds is actually the limit.
300 pounds is the limit for this little rebounding trampoline.
And it's got the bungee cords
and it does have safety locks,
so it's never gonna like, unfold,
because you'd be surprised at how small this comes
when it comes to you. It's got Protection,
so it's never gonna, like,
collapse while you're using it.
You're good. And this is literally
one of the most low impact exercises you can do for your body.
That is has the same effect as jogging.
Like 10, I think it's like
15 minutes on the little trampoline is equivalent to like
a 30 minute run outside.
But you don't have the same pressure on your joints and everything.
So especially if you're at a higher weight
and you're trying to really get down,
you're not just doing it to maintain.
This little thing is amazing. It's linked right here.